who's going to be the 2024 republican
nominee
donald trump
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry
i'm frances foster i'm constant kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
our brilliant guest today is many many
things he's an intelligent analyst he's
a former deputy assistant to president
donald trump
radio host now tv host of the gorkha
reality check and of course
author of this book the war for america
soul dr sebastian gorka welcome to
trigonometry
cheers guys just call me seb please we
will do seb
thanks for coming on the show uh that is
probably the longest intro we've ever
done but let's
let's make it a bit longer tell us a
little bit about who are you
what has been your journey through life
how do you find yourself sitting here
talking to
two very problematic people like us uh
yeah you mean two bigots
let me start with with with something
else first
so i and don't take this the wrong way
guys
i am just stunned that it takes
a jewish kid from russia and a half
venezuelan brit
to have what i consider to be one of the
most substantive
podcasts anywhere you you are the
interesting serious joe rogans and you
keep me sane guys so god bless both of
you
it's very kind thanks seb that is very
very kind seb and being a british person
that was a compliment and i really don't
know how to deal with it apart from
offer
a kind of thinly veiled insult uh but
you're gonna turn them back to drink at
this rate yeah exactly and on top of
that
on top of that i do not having grown up
in the uk
knowing the relationship the brits have
to alcohol and i know it's been a tough
year
under covid so i don't want to encourage
more drinking
but i have to say the recent raw that
you guys did lanyard
was hilarious even funnier than usual
and i do think i do think ff you should
write that book
that keto is for slags that that
cookbook
should be written all right um so you
realize this is going out to the real
public now right
all right so so who's seb gorka um born
in the uk
to parents who escaped communist hungary
in the revolution in 1956
um my dad actually being liberated from
a political communist prison by the
freedom fighters
he was arrested tortured that imprisoned
and uh
first actually betrayed by kim philby in
mi6
got a life sentence at the age of 20
liberated escaped with
the uh 17 year old daughter of a fellow
prison mate across the minefields into
austria and then over to the uk
those are my parents um how am i where i
am today why do i believe what i believe
there's a story in one of my books we
were on the beach
on holiday when i was a kid maybe seven
eight years old
my dad came out of the ocean they tried
to break him as a man but they didn't
break him physically or mentally
he came out of the ocean after a swim
and like a dumb kid
i asked him a question about these lines
i saw on his wrist
and i said dad what are those because he
was too
too young to be wrinkled without
skipping a beat
he uh he without emotion said son
that's where the secret police bound my
wrists together behind my back
with wire so so they could hang me from
the ceiling of the torture chamber
that's when my life changed inexorably
that's when i realized that you know
concepts like evil
aren't just from grimm's tales or hansel
and gretel
evil is real it walks the earth and
communism is the most evil ideology
we've ever seen
and so i've dedicated my professional
career to um
national security i worked in the u.s
defense department
teaching irregular warfare
counterterrorism met my american wife
in europe teaching a counterterrorism
program after 9 11
and then eventually ended up here we
moved to america in 2008
hoping we would leave socialism behind
us in europe
sadly america elected obama uh
and then we had to suffer under that and
then eventually
um i wrote a couple of books on the
threat of al-qaeda and isis one of them
got to the attention of candidate donald
trump
and to cut a a a longer story
slightly shorter i ended up in the white
house
in the first year of the trump
administration as deputy assistant and
strategist to donald trump
my thing is grand strategy national
security
and just fighting totalitarians wherever
we see them whether it's
global jihadists or whether it's the
purveyors of
critical race theory now here in the
united states
and seb uh you are probably as far on to
the maggot train as we've gone in terms
of our interviews and as you know
neither francis or i were particularly
big fans of your former employer
uh we are some we politically are
probably far to the left of you in terms
of being in the center
um but what we really wanted to talk to
you about rather than going 12 rounds
with you on some tweet that donald trump
did or whatever we can talk about that
a little bit later perhaps in a more you
know more nuanced way
uh what we wanted to talk to you about
is what donald trump represented when i
think of donald trump the image
i see as a sort of viking berserker
breaking through a wall
uh and taking all the first arrows and
you know it's not necessarily the guy
you want your daughter to bring home
uh you know but but but sometimes they
can be necessary
even though it's not necessarily the
nicest guy if you like um
what do you think his election
represented first of all
well i like that that description of a
berserker
one of the regular guests on my radio
show who i consider to be
one of the greatest minds alive today is
victor davis hanson
and he he gave a presentation about you
know the need of the ajax the need of
the patent the these uncivilized
individuals
that are needed from time to time to
actually save civilization and i very
much see
my former boss donald trump in that
light so what happened in 2016
um i i don't know about you i love to
read i collect
i have you know two uh serious health
conditions
i can't walk past a bookstore without
buying a book and or past a gun store
without buying a gun
so i love to collect guns i love to
collect books i don't however read
autobiographies i have no patience for
these
you know 900 page books on what
eisenhower had for breakfast
on february the 12th 1945 however
in the past 20 years i've read two
autobiographies that changed my life
one of them we can talk about later is
andrew breitbart's righteous indignation
which is a he caught himself a
thoughtless
drunk leftist and his journey to
conservativism
and his chapter six if if your viewers
your really informed viewers want to
understand how we got to where we are
today with
the whole of the british establishment
trying to stop brexit
with the whole of the u.s establishment
on both sides trying to stop
trump you've got to read chapter six of
breitbart's
righteous indignation but the other book
which is crucial i mean utterly
seminal to understanding what happened
here in 2016
is jd vance's hillbilly elegy
now jd vance was not he was not a fan of
donald trump
he is he has become more maggot in
recent years given the council culture
but his story of how he grew up as the
scion of an
appalachian clan working class americans
from the hills
hillbillies who came from a culture that
had a future
could get jobs in the factories could
feed their their kids
to a a subculture that was destroyed
by left and right betrayed by by the
republicans and the democrats for 50
years with their
jobs shipped over to asia riven with
drug abuse his mart
he grew up in a single mother household
mother was a drug addict
that man's story of how he climbed out
of that
and the broader context of what the
political elites had done
to the working class is an eye-opener
and i'll express it with just one
empirical data point
i find it amusing that you know an
immigrant to america
with an accent has to constantly remind
my fellow americans
what we actually did in 2016
because from 1776 until 2016 we had 44
presidential
administrations every stinking one of
them
was led by a member of the political
elite
either a congressman a senator a former
governor
as president or a retired general like
washington or
eisenhower every single president
was a member of the in set
in 2016 65 million americans said
screw that we want an
utter outsider and it found sounds funny
you know billionaire from manhattan
but he was an outsider hated by the
establishment not just the left
but the republican establishment
detested him made fun of him
and we chose a man who'd never even run
for
any political office to the highest
office of the land so
you know politics changed in a way in
2016 and and thanks in part and i have
to give you guys credit
it starts with nigel and it starts with
with brexit
the the re-assertion of representative
government which the left
derisively calls populism which is quite
ironic because what does populism mean
it's popular with most of the people
which is kind of like a definition of
democracy as far as i'm concerned
but it is this pejorative phrase today
so in 2016
uh we you know the american people black
white
working class not working class sent a
message to this city behind me
enough enough enough it stops now
so it's a very very good point that
you're making so
really what you're saying is that the
reason trump got elected
was because there was a backlash against
globalization
yeah so let me let me talk about
personal experience so i flew with the
president
to youngstown ohio on air force one and
youngstown is called it's called steel
valley it is one of the the the
epicenters of the steel industry as was
we landed on a on a military base
because you know he had the convoy and
the beast and everything else he gets
off the plane we get into the convoy
it's about a 20-minute ride to the
stadium where where you know there's
going to be a maga rally this was
in 2017. and it's fascinating
20-minute drive on the left-hand side
all we see
one after another are these disused
steel mills
these foundries that are decaying empty
on the right hand side for 20 minutes
guys
we see kids we see moms we see
out of work dads with their little
american flags
waving at the president's convoy we get
to the arena 24th out i mean just packed
arena bosses in the back i'm taking
selfies with the people who are there
and i it's clear to me 99 of the people
in this building
are either former democrats or their
dads or their grandads were
in the mill and they were working class
democrats
the billionaire from manhattan walks out
on the stage
actually was the first lady and then and
then the president
and guys i kid you not you can watch the
footage
donald trump the billionaire from
manhattan
couldn't start his speech for minutes
because the crowd was screaming
usa usa drain the swamp
this is in one of the hardest core
democrat strongholds in america
you're absolutely right it was a it was
an up yours
to the globalists and their
representatives on both sides of the
political aisle
who had screwed the people who built
america for decades that's what happened
in 2016.
and uh seb i know what your answer to
this question is going to be so i'm just
going to preempt it by saying i think we
probably all three of us agree that if
it weren't for cover donald trump wins
again in 2020
but the fact that he didn't win the fact
that this happened
and uh joe biden is now president what
does that mean
for populism because i think the
underlying sentiment
some of the the the boil was lance
somewhat the past has run
somewhat do you think now people will
sort of
you know i'll be honest with you i don't
miss donald trump i don't miss the
rhetoric i don't miss the constant
outrage all the time about him do you
think a lot of people will be like okay
look
the elite got the the shot across the
bows they're going to stop as we say
in england taking the piss and you know
we move on
hopefully someone comes in who's you
know gonna adopt some of donald trump's
policies that were popular with the very
people you're talking about but he'll be
less
obnoxious to the public leb so you know
different in terms of his behavior
uh maybe like a dan crenshaw or someone
of that sort of ilk
uh is that the way it's gonna go or do
you think that land that boil never got
properly launched and it's just gonna
keep growing and then get last again
so here are the most important data
points in in the last four months or
since since the election the last seven
months
thirty percent of democrats guys thirty
percent of the people who voted for
biden
believe the election was fraudulent
that's a problem i believe maybe 60 to
70 percent
of trump voters think it was stolen
so whether or not populism survives
is one question the other question is
does the majority of this nation's
population actually believe in the
fundamental
uh sacred right that we have to choose
our own
political leaders whichever party they
come from
we have a a sucking chest wound we have
a lethal wound
at the heart of our political structures
that has to be fixed first before we can
even get to the other questions of
leading style and and and policies
secondly if you look at the interests of
the globalists
they are more powerful than they have
ever been that they're pushing the
envelope to such extremes especially
with
critical race theory that there's
already a backlash but what we've
witnessed
think about this in in the first month
biden wrote more than 100 executive
orders
this is these are things that don't go
through the senate they're just you know
decrees coming out of the white house
this is from a man who seven months
prior during the debate said
only dictators ruled by executive order
that's what he said and that's what he's
doing
how have the globalists fared since
january the 20th
and the inauguration bloody well i mean
really well
the xl keystone pipeline i'm getting
into specifics here but there was a
pipeline that we built with canada
that was crucial to jobs in america on
the first day in office
he killed it donald trump had made it
possible biden killed it
on that one day one day 11 000 americans
lost their jobs
and and senator kerry who's now the
climate czar for biden
this arrogant [ __ ] who who who
globe trots in his private jet married
into the heinz family has gone on record
to say
yeah well uh th those oil rig workers
they can get jobs in the solar industry
i mean just classic arrogant
elitist uh yeah i'm gonna up sticks from
texas and move to
you know massachusetts with my family
and my six kids
and not only that when you talk to the
canadians lord conrad black
regular guest on my show he says both
sides of the political spectrum in
canada
are apoplectic because it may be 11 000
jobs in america
in canada it was 36 000
jobs that were killed with that one
executive order
so whether it's cow tang to china
whether it's allowing
russia to have its north stream
pipeline with germany whether it's
bending over backwards to big
tech globalism is stronger than it ever
was
and i i wrote a piece i sent you guys
and i know you don't want to talk about
trump exclusively and i get it but i
i pray that he comes back in 2024 for
one reason
we have some serious [ __ ] to fix in dc
i mean we have some real that i didn't
use the phrase deep state when i joined
the administration
i thought it was tinfoil hat kind of
conspiracy theory
and then i saw it then i saw what they
did to general flynn then i saw what
they did to
roger stone and others it's real we have
people who are seditious
unelected subversives who are very
powerful bureaucrats
and who believe that their writ
outweighs the writ
of the electorate who chooses the
president so
i want to see in your words uh
constantine
i want to see that berserker back in the
office and i want to see
i want to see a flamethrower applied to
these people who think they're better
than their fellow american
so that we can actually get them out of
these bureaucratic strongholds
and i don't care about the tweets god
bless him in his tweets i think he
prevented
world war three in north korea with his
tweets about little kim
we need a man the the delightful thing
look i i went to a
a public school in west london i spent
13 years in a benedictine
you know school stiff upper lip debating
society all that jazz
you think it wasn't hard for me to get
used to this guy
because what you see is what you get he
is a kid from queens he's not
georgetown he's not manhattan he is a
kid from queens it took me
some getting used to but the greatest
thing about donald trump in an
era of rising unaccountable globalist
bureaucracies is there are no sacred
cows for this man
he comes in if he sees something that's
wrong whether it's our relations with
israel whether it's the the working
class being screwed
he goes about his darndest to fix it so
we need four more years of the berserker
in the white house because otherwise
you're seeing it already you're seeing
you know all these
swamp creature republicans 10 senators
and then 23 congressmen who voted to
impeach
their own leader they they see donald
trump as an anomaly
and as soon as he's gone we can get back
to business and we can scratch the
democrats backs and they'll scratch ours
i don't want that i want representative
government
for as many of the people who live here
irrespective of their class or their
skin color
and and the stunning thing about donald
trump
is he wanted only two things and you
don't have to take my word for it
but guys but if you're watching read my
books i'll give you my testimony
he wanted two things for everybody in
america if you're here
legally he wants you to be safe and he
wants you to prosper
and the remarkable thing is he wanted
that for you
whether or not you voted for him that is
not the attitude
of the democrats who right now and i'd
love to talk about this
are criminalizing conservatives
how do i know that january the 6th we
had people trespass on congress
they didn't kill anybody they didn't
shoot anybody there are people on
trespass
charges who have been sitting in federal
jails just behind me in solitary
since january that happens in a police
state
and nobody from blm or antifa has been
sitting in solitary
for five months that's what really keeps
me awake at night
so sorry but this you know with my
background this stuff
really gets to me right but you say that
said but
surely you know what they did was
incredibly serious
incredible they need to pay the price
don't get me wrong if you went in there
if you nicked you know nancy pelosi's
laptop if you
broke up somebody's office get charged
in front of a jury of your peers and pay
the penalty
but but hang on a second when kamala
harris
is raising bail money for antifa
activists to get let out of prison but
somebody who trespassed and broke a
window
is in solitary confinement for five
months
that's not that's not that's not
equality before the law
that is the use of the police as a
police
state for political purposes they need
to be punished
but they don't need to be punished for
political reasons
well uh you look there's an argument to
be had there sir because what they did
was also
a political act because it was an
attempt to stop a vote from happening
uh in in in congress right so right
right but we but we don't have a system
that is meant to do political policing
is is very is something you and i and
all three of us probably agree on
so we don't need to get into that and if
people are sitting in solitary which i
actually didn't know for all this time
and that sounds wrong to me on on the
surface but look i
i take it if you don't mind me saying by
the way you avoided my question about
populism that
you do think it's run out of steam i
i don't think it's run out of steam um i
i think there are
forces there are retrenchment of forces
that want to undermine populism and i
think there's a lot of people
and i see this you know the callers to
my show and what have you who say
that's it they stole it i'm never voting
again
that that's a really disturbing attitude
and i tell them really
you've given up on america what what
would the founding fathers say
who took on the british empire that's
that's a very un-american attitude
i think populism the the the rejection
of globalism is alive it's like i think
you were talking to somebody one of your
guests
it's you know once you've voted brexit
once you've voted
anti-establishment i think maybe you
made this point or maybe frances
once you've gone to your establishment
once you're not gonna go back
right once you've set up yours to the
establishment
even if you're a labor voter all your
life once you vote against
labor because you see them as the
establishment now
you're not going to suddenly bounce back
so i think that
the populist sentiment is out there
amongst the
74 75 million people that voted for
donald trump
but there are these very very powerful
poor forces
of the rhinos the republicans in name
only
the establishment politicians who say ah
flash in the pan he's an irrelevance
let's get back to the old way of doing
business so i am worried for populism
and i don't see outside of maybe the
governor of florida
i don't see a lot of people who have
that you know balls to the wall
you know bulldog spirit and want to
fight fight the
the globalists but seb isn't the problem
also as well that you know we're talking
you know about trump and the role
of the president isn't one of the the
subjects that we're not really
addressing is the power of the
corporations who dare i say it are
probably more powerful than the
president himself
absolutely i mean i think about this
well
not just i mean the corporations and
social media why was he so detested
and it's just very simple mathematics
donald trump was utterly detested by
every element of the elite because
nobody owned him
he he never you know been funded had
never had donors from big
pharma from big tech he wasn't in the
pocket of the unions
everybody hated him that's why he could
come out as a republican president
constantly hammering big pharma saying
what how much is insulin how much are
you charging americans for insulin
that's a bloody crime and he went to war
with
farmer that's not a popular thing to do
is a politician
so you know corporations of course hate
populism because they're not
national entities uh ibm isn't nash
isn't a national entity
nike with its sweatshops in xinjiang uh
china with its slave labor you know
trainer makers
they're not an american company anymore
so you're absolutely right but even more
dangerous
is silicon valley and palo alto you
your viewers may not be familiar but
think of this one thing
mark zuckerberg the founder the ceo of
facebook
through his ngo dropped 400 million
dollars
in the last election not as campaign
contributions to candidates
but to local governments to help
control how the elections are
actually run to quote-unquote train
election officials
and for example once the governors
change the laws unilaterally
to put ballot drop boxes where
in democrat stronghold districts
almost half a billion dollars of private
money
into the actual running of elections
that should be a crime i don't care who
you're voting for
but when facebook and when fate went
when twitter
the oldest newspaper in america is the
new york post okay it was it was it was
founded by one of the founding fathers
when the new york post
gets the access to hunter biden's laptop
which is his laptop because when your
lawyers
demand to get it back from the the
repair shop
owner that means it's hunter biden's
laptop when the story
of the the emails with russia the
barista
no-show job for 83 000 a month the fact
that his company was in bed with the
chief spy of communist china and we have
hunter biden's
voicemail where he admits it on the
laptop when that story blew in the new
york post before the election
and jack dorsey made it impossible to
post it on twitter
if you posted it it was delete the new
york times
own post of the story was memory hold
like
all well then then i don't know which is
worse
big corporations or twitter and facebook
this is very very disturbing and of
course none of these people believe in
america first or american jobs or the
working class they hate the working
class
which then goes back to my point is then
how do you
stand up to these people when they've
got such money such power
doesn't that therefore mean that they
can't be controlled it's too late
uh look i'm an american now by choice
and uh even before that it was part of
my character but i do believe it's a
fundamental characteristic of most
americans where
we're optimists by by by by dint of how
we were created i mean
remember in 1776 uh the the british
colonists
only two and a half percent of whom
actually fought the british
it was it wasn't the color it was less
than three percent actually fought the
redcoats
they took on the biggest empire the
world had ever seen i mean the persians
were pikers the
the roman empire were amateurs by
comparison to the british empire
on which the sun truly never set so the
idea that a bunch of ragtag crazies
could could defeat the the british
empire
is kind of in the gene code of americans
we don't know the word surrender so
the idea that we're just gonna say okay
that's it we're just heading on
the slow road to venezuela i i don't
think that's what most americans
are in for and what what the beauty of
our system
is the electoral college that we have
this it's not 50
plus one it is a weighted system where
the you know the smallest state like
rhode island
has almost as much power as texas that
the the electoral college system for
choosing the president
isn't just you know the majority can
dictate and then
the minority can go to hell so we have
certain safeties
uh i have issues with the states of the
supreme court the role of
of judges today who are either activists
or cowards
but when it comes to corporations i i'm
not prepared to to say okay that's it
it's over i'm just not prepared to say
that and i truly believe when you get
out of places like dc
when you get out of la new york boston
the majority of americans
are not defeatist and and they will
stand up remember it's 74 million people
your biden may or may not have won
quote unquote but donald trump received
more
votes than any incumbent president in
the history of america
now that's something to be reckoned with
if so i'm talking to a lot of people
people with big pockets
if somebody was smart enough to create
one platform that was a twitter a
facebook an
email service a news aggregator like
drudge before drudge went insane
that actually catered to people who
believed in america
that believed that nation states and the
west failing system are good
you maybe actually have an audience
potential audience
of 74 million buyers that is
real power you've just got to invest
you've got to build it
and you know why i'm optimistic and this
isn't a cop out i truly believe this
every day you guys may not see this but
every day
i come into the studio and there's
another viral video
of some mom in new york some teacher in
virginia standing up at a local school
board and saying
this bigotry this critical race theory
this veiled marxism
we're not going to let you indoctrinate
our kids every day there's a new one
today
so that gives me hope guys
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website
well if you do then easy dns of the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be cancel culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50 percent off
the initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy
that tells you everything you need to
know about technology
privacy and censorship well seb you
mentioned
critical race theory and this is
something that conservatives like you
talk about a lot at the moment it's also
something that concerns
me uh or at least i i don't claim to
really know exactly
the nuances of critical race theory i
just think uh
teaching people that some races are
better than others is probably not a
good idea because like you i've read a
little bit of history but
um tell me what is critical race theory
before we get into talking about it
all right well the formal answer is it's
a it's a
it's a way of looking at justice in the
world that was
named by derrick bell uh it's
interesting when
when we won the cold war in 1989 when
the west won and the you know the east
germans took down the berlin wall the
very same year there was a conference
where derrick bell a radical law
professor from harvard
coined the term critical race theory but
it's built upon a much much longer
progression
uh that that is basically the the
inculcation of
marxist thought into academia in general
so let's let's just i mean your viewers
may know this but let's unpack it for a
second
uh communism was meant to create
revolutions around the world because
there's there's a inherent tension in in
all societies of the oppressed and the
oppressor
the working class and the capitalist
marx stole
from hegel and he took his version of
the dialectic and said
there's there's this material version of
the dialectic and sooner or later the
tension between the oppressed and the
oppressor
is going to explode in a revolution and
that's when we get justice in a
classless society
well the sad thing is for the communists
it was a failure it was garbage it was
false science
the only place where it could work were
backward feudal states
like tsarist russia or or china in 1948
after the quoming tang
where you didn't have a strong middle
class that was robust and had
judeo-christian values and said this is
this philosophy's
crackers i'm not gonna subscribe to it
in in robust
western societies with a strong middle
class and and christian or
judeo-christian values
they needed a new they needed a new
angle of attack and this is where the
new left and neo-marxism comes in
built upon antonio gramsci's concepts
there's this crippled italian communist
in one of mussolini's prison cells
writes his political work
saying in a in a developed society you
can't have a revolution of the working
class
the middle class is too robust so you
can't go frontally against them
you've got to undermine them from the
inside and it's the long march through
the institutions this is where the
frankfurt school adorno marcusa
and so forth come where they say you got
to capture the culture
how do you capture the culture you've
got to take the
class-based tension
and you flip it and you say what are the
what are the other ways
we can engender tension in a robust
society with middle class
if it's not going to be class it's going
to be sexual
identity it's going to be race
and this is where critical race theory
comes in critical race theory says
that oppression is endemic in western
civilization
even if they don't know it white
men especially white heterosexual men
are inherently
oppressive and there has to be
a a forced redress
this is not equality but equity the
system
has to push down the oppressor
constantly
so that the the minorities can find that
their just place that's really you know
the concept of critical race theory
that that's i mean it is the antithesis
of martin luther king it's saying
skin color is actually connected
to attributes that you cannot ever get
rid of
and especially the white world is guilty
that's critical race theory and it's now
very it's pervasive through u.s schools
and it's being injected into the new the
us military by the
new administration and said you know
we're talking about critical race here
and you say it's being injected into
schools but
as a theory surely it should be allowed
to be taught in colleges as a theory
like you would study a range of other
theories like comments right yeah but
but we're not talking about college
we're talking about pre-k we're talking
about kindergarten
i mean this is the shocking story and
it's not it's not
taught as a theory amongst other
theories
it is taught as the world view
so there are stories of of kids in very
very well-to-do posh families in
manhattan
where this stuff is out of control in
the private schools i mean really
really sad stories of these kids coming
home
and saying to their mom mommy am i a
racist because i'm white
that's that's not the teaching of a
theory
that is indoctrination when when you
have people
being shamed in you know in front of
their class having to stand up
um because you're white and apologize
for slavery in 2021 that's not you know
teaching the difference between
neoliberal neoclassicist theories of
international relations
that is that is orwellian north korean
indoctrination
this is the self-criticism of of the
maoists
that we saw with the great leap forward
and the cultural revolution where
you have to publicly shame yourself in
front of
others because of your skin color so
teaching as a theory
yeah that would that would be not an
issue but when a
six-year-old is being told you need to
apologize because you're
white that's indoctrination
it is look all of that is abhorrent to
me
um but does it would you not say that
obviously look everything you've said
about the history of this
i completely agree with the the the the
they kind of understood at one point
that you can't get the working class to
rise up if they think that someday
they'll be wealthy too
which is the the essence of the american
dream right right you can't get them to
eat the rich if they all think that
someday they may well be rich because
they live in a society where that's
possible
um but do you not also think that
whether we we can disagree about
or agree frankly whether critical race
theory makes sense or not whether it's
accurate
the desire for some kind of what you
described as equity where you press
down on one group to elevate another
comes from the fact
that the the western world
is unequal and there is racial
inequality
that is baked into the cake of the the
story of our countries and
we see it in this country where
communities from certain
parts of the world struggle now i'm not
saying by the way that's to do with skin
color there are different things going
on and we've talked about them
on our show as you know but
the fact is that an unequal society
which which claims to be just and fair
uh isn't that and so the desire to
equalize is sort of coming from a good
place even though
i agree with you i don't think the
outcomes are going to be anything like
what these people are suggesting i'm
kind of
i don't know if you're being a devil's
advocate and kind of shocked
given given your family background that
you've even raised that i mean look
you've had j to the b to the ever-loving
p on your show
and you know if he's the not the most
eloquent
uh um person on this issue
okay there there is no utopia on earth i
get it fine
um but who's going to decide who gets
the biggest slice of the pie and who's
going to decide
well well now it's okay now blacks are
all right
or yellow or whatever i have got enough
who's going to decide that and me
so my background i'm a mutt from central
europe okay
my name is polish my parents were
hungarian my mom's got a little bit of
turkish in her
there's a little bit of jewish somewhere
possibly
i was born in the uk and i'm an
immigrant to the united states but i'm
white
so do do i have to be punished
do some of my income have to go to a
black person who
was born here whose parents were
jamaican and were never slaves you see
that you know
the the the the the absurdity this
becomes a monty python skittle after a
while
it's it's it's the equality of outcomes
versus the
quality of opportunity and and look i i
go back to growing up in west london
i grew up in healing healing back in the
70s was one of the most diverse parts of
london
because you know after world war ii
members of the free polish army were
given housing there
i went to school with my mates were you
know my best mate was a pakistani the
other guy was polish
german there was only one kid out of
600. one kid
who who could prove he was actually
english english going back a few
generations
and and the school bus driver on the
number 65 bus
was a jamaican with a thick jamaican
accent we all thought all of us
were brits right and i think that's the
way it should be
the idea that i or my dad a refugee from
hungary should be punished
in favor of the black bus driver's
future
that's that's insanity and at the end of
the day i'll let me be clear
have you guys been to america yeah yeah
we both yeah
okay um i've lived in england
i've lived for 15 years in a
post-communist country after the war
fell
i worked for the first freely elected uh
conservative government in hungary
i've traveled the world from japan to
africa you name it and i can tell you
right now hand on heart
hand on the good book there is no nation
um
less racist than america the idea that a
black
kid from a single mother household
could become the president of the united
states is all
the proof you need if you work your
ass off you will be successful in this
country you may not be a neuroscientist
scientist like ben carson a black member
of the trump administration who was the
first
neuro brain surgeon to separate
conjoined twins in america
who likewise grew up in a single mother
household where his mother
couldn't read but he ends up in the
cabinet of the president
you know think of this i'm a flipping
immigrant i only became an immigrant in
2012
and five years later i'm walking around
the white house deputy assistant to the
president
it still blows my mind if i hadn't gone
to harold or eaton
i wouldn't be doing that in the uk in 10
downing street
i know that i know if you've got the
wrong name if your name is mohammed
and you apply for a white collar job in
marseille you are
screwed in france i've seen real racism
in the countries i've lived in so the
idea that we have a pro
we are you know this is the only nation
that went to war with itself
to end bigotry more people
died in the civil war in america than in
all the other wars combined you combine
the deaths from world war one world war
ii in vietnam
it doesn't come close 600 000
americans died to end slavery in the
civil war
and some [ __ ] at the new york times is
going to lecture me
on my whiteness being a guilt i have to
pay off to somebody
whose melanin level in their skin is a
little bit darker than mine
that way lies tyranny because who's
going to decide
who gets what it's the ultimate question
of communism who gets to decide
who gets to decide okay now you've had
enough reparations and we can all
live happily i saw it myself i went to
harvard in the 90s
and i saw these kids who came on
affirmative action to harvard
they couldn't cut it they felt awkward
and they created tension with the people
who were maybe asian who'd worked their
tails after getting to harvard and saw
this person walking on a ticket because
he's the right skin color
that way you actually engender racial
tension
you don't solve anything so no i i agree
with you know
jordan peterson and everybody else who's
looked at this for decades
it's it's equality of opportunity
and it cannot be a quality of outcome
because who's going to enforce that
and i agree with you said that it does
need to be equality of opportunity
but the problem is when you have a
society like america
there isn't equality of opportunity is
there i mean let's be fair
why not if obama can make it to
president if ben
carson could make it into the cabinet as
black kids from single parent households
where where where where is the systemic
lack of opportunity well for you for
example if someone grows up
incredibly poor in a deprived
neighborhood with high crime rates
that it's going to be far more difficult
for them especially if they go to a
school that is failing that has got
literacy rates through the floor
numeracy rates through the floor
each look as as a former teacher it that
kid
has got it far tougher than somebody
else who goes through a very prestigious
private school in manhattan
and gets you know you know
it's very easy for them not very easy
much easier for them right
and and what has happened in the last 60
years since the great society
what was created we've sunk
literally trillions of dollars into
those
inner cities into those ghettos with
what effect
the the average poverty rate in america
is exactly the same as it was under lbj
exactly the same despite the trillions
of dollars sunken into them why
because a culture of dependency was
created
and the teachers union said what do you
mean you want to have a voucher system
where a black mother can choose where
their kid goes to school we don't want
voucher systems we want state schools
based upon the union precincts and you
go to the flipping school that's in your
district
what we've created is we what what is
the answer to these things
well so let me interrupt you there uh
very respectfully because
all of the failures of the left we've
covered as you well know on ourselves
quite thoroughly but but here's what i'm
asking you and i think this is actually
an opportunity
uh for your side of the conversation to
come up with
some answers what is your offering
what is your solution to some of those
problems when francis talks about and
you you know this full well that in
certain neighborhoods in america
kids can't read at the age of 15 and
they can't write and
they they don't have certain role models
they don't have access to opportunities
and by the time they're 18
there's no way they're getting the job
because they've got a criminal record
and they've got no
understanding of how to conduct
themselves and whatever so what is the
conservative answer to that lack of
equality of opportunity that
we all so much believe in i i can't do
it better
than my my salem radio colleague larry
elder
it's you know the the success in life
whatever your skin card is very
very simple finish school
and get married and don't have
kids before you're married if
if we i mean the the fact that 70
percent of black children are born to
fatherless homes
that's the problem not how much money is
spent in inner city chicago
the problem is the role of faith of
contradiction
of of family values
larry's absolutely right you've gotta
you've gotta break the unions you've
gotta give parents the power to choose
where their kids go to school
schools have got to be competitive and
we've got to have this
d disincentivization of people to be
unmarried and have kids if you're in the
city of chicago
you're going to get more money from the
state if you're not married
and have kids from five different guys
how is that good for the children that
you're having it's like
god knows i agree with you and since you
bring up larry elder the one thing that
i think makes him an outlier in this
conversation
and an issue that we agree with him very
strongly on is the war on drugs
i think that's been a huge contributor
to this conversation i i and i'm
i'm sorry to see that not many
conservatives want to talk about it what
is your take on on that side of it
uh you're not going to like it you know
i i i'm a complete
purist on this stuff i've seen enough
down i i've seen
relatives who may have just done you
know soft drugs who've thrown away their
lives
i'm not a big i think i think the the
the the
criminalization of the user
is not the way to go i think we have to
try and get people
off drugs as much as we can but i think
the i'm not a libertarian
i think libertarians it's one of the
dumbest philosophies out there
because it it doesn't uh factor in
secondary and tertiary consequences of
of the libertine lifestyle
you've got to have you know it's it's
the broken window policy for me
right you know a little infraction
eventually leads to a large infraction
and at the end of the day i'm i'm a
purist when it comes to drugs although i
do think the way
we have spent money on the war of drugs
is absolutely
insane people should be helped but if
you're a dealer who's destroying lives
you should be banged up for life as far
as i'm concerned well c
sub this is where i the reason i really
admire
elements of thinking on the right and
this is why i talk about me being a
centrist because
i i really am interested in a lot of
thoughts on the left and the right
because i think both have some good
ideas
the the one thing that i always admire
about the right is the pragmatism it's
not it's not ideology first as it often
is on the left it's
what works and we know this thing the
war on drugs
does not work right and that's what i
and my argument for ending the war on
drugs there's nothing to do with
libertarianism which is not an ideology
i particularly share
it's to do with the fact that i don't
think it's working and i think you need
to do something else
and so i my approach isn't to just say
you know take heroin whatever
it's to get people the help they need to
not be addicts but also to allow
responsible adults to put
in their body frankly what they choose
to if they're being responsible
about it and they don't need the help my
my
you know it's not something i've spent a
lot of time looking at i've never taken
any drugs in my life so it's not
something that i
i've seen others and and it's been
horrifying you know what's happened to
them
but i think the answer is you it cannot
be solved by government
right that's the bottom line it's got to
be solved by
private initiative by uh people
organizations
churches as social workers helping but
not
government and if it's the if it's a
dealer if it's hard drugs
that remains a crime but the end user no
those people need to be
helped to create a a a a to become
functioning individuals it's like it's
like mental health if you guys haven't
been to america recently
dc is now tent city of homeless people
ninety percent of them are have mental
issues
in los angeles uh in in san francisco
this is a massive problem why because we
have said
in those municipalities their civil
rights trounce everything else
unless they're actively killing people
or hurting themselves
you can't give them any assistance so
people spend decades
on the street mumbling to themselves i
don't think that's good for them
i think it's actually inhuman and we
need to help them
but not governments we have to allow
private organizations to help them but
we don't because we say
hey civil rights let them inject
whatever they want let them have a [ __ ]
on the sidewalk
that's freedom i i don't think it's good
for them and i don't think it's good for
society
yeah it's a very good point seb one
thing that i wanted to move the
conversation on before the interview
ended go
what is the future of the republican
party and what is the future of
conservatism
because we saw with trump he moved
the conserve the the conversation in one
particular direction
he changed the republican party forever
what do you think is going to be the
future republicanism and conservatism in
general
i don't think these words function
anymore i think the taxonomy
of conservative republican labor
democrat i i think these labels are bust
that they're broken uh
as i said in an event last night you
know donald trump in 2016 he took the
political rule book
he ripped it up shredded it lit it
alight buried it and dropped up and down
on it so the political landscape
especially after brexit after
modi after uh you know donald trump is
is is completely different it is a race
between
two forms of populism it is the populism
of those who believe in their countries
whether it's the uk whether it's india
whether it's america
and it is a populism based upon uh
global elites where where bernie sanders
and aoc
says we've got to save the planet
uh we've got to take control of
information supplies
social media has to ban certain kinds of
people
certain kinds of comedians can't tell
certain kinds of jokes
because we are in a global fight to for
social justice
that's how i see you know the the future
of politics it's going to be new labels
new actors
and i think the biggest change is um
and i see this coming up in the next
election i think
uh successful national politicians
especially in america
will not come from the political
establishment it's going to have to be
outsiders i'm not talking about oprah
but i'm talking about
you know it's got to be celebrities who
are untainted
by having been politicians who can
actually
ride that wave of populism whether it's
coming from a traditional right or a
traditional left i think that's the
biggest impact on politics writ large
who's going to be the 2024 republican
nominee
donald trump you don't think he's gonna
how will he be then 82 seb
he just turned 75 last week
okay so not not as old as you thought
that's interesting
yeah i saw him last week i went to new
york um
before i met before i saw him i i
publicly said i give it 95
chance that he's running after i saw him
i'm going to give it a 98
chance that he's running if he runs he
gets the nomination and if the
disastrous policies of the last four
months continue
for the next three years he's going to
stroll back into the white house
if if we can have some transparency on
the way we run elections in america
and you don't think that the events of
what happened on that day in january uh
have tainted his legacy at all
no i i think they they could have
if nancy pelosi hadn't tried to impeach
him a second time after he left office
with that incredibly stupid move
nancy pelosi allowed him back into the
political arena because it was
clear that they were trying to persecute
a man who'd left political office so
he was in trouble um before that but
when she tried to
kick him out of the white house after he
left the white house
he was back in action and and sure
enough in in uh 12 days
he's got his first rally so he's going
to be out doing his manga rallies
so we'll do some questions for locals in
a minute but i want to stick with the
donald trump
point for a second he obviously enjoys
tremendous popularity with a very large
section of the american public to this
day
that's very clear do you think that is
because people are desperate and they
don't see someone who still
still don't see anyone else who
represents them or do you think
he actually delivered for them in his
first term
well i i i think you know if you're if
you're a policy wonk
like i am you know you you look at what
he delivered from crushing isis securing
the wall
getting serious on russia biggest
economy sorry what do you mean about
securing the wall did he finish the wall
no no i mean the the the illegal
immigrants we got illegal
immigration down to a trickle especially
after covid
even without the wall because we had
something called title 42 that meant
because of the covet infection if you
cross the board really
illegally we could deport you straight
away so he had powers under under covid
that we'd never had before
which meant we had we had a fraction
of the of the illegal crossings by by
october of last year but no he didn't
get to finish the war
so so getting a grip on illegal
migration crushing isis
uh lowest unemployment for blacks and
hispanics since since record keeping
began
so i mean just on a policy platform
amazing success
but i think really why why um he's going
to be popular again is what you said at
the beginning
uh constantine he's a berserker and
people are fed up but people
just don't trust the establishment
whether they're a a pipe fitter in in
you know in long island
whether they're a farmer in you know in
in in texas
or or whether they're a working-class
guy who's kind of
kind of sick with what he's seen happen
to his family in the last 40 years
they want berserkers to break some china
and
donald trump is good at that yeah
you are right we will see what happens
seb seb uh how about we do this deal if
he runs again and you're in the white
house uh
we really appreciate coming on give me
an hour of your time i will destroy the
war on drugs with facts and logic
and you can sell it to the president how
about that uh
why don't why don't you come on we can
i'll i'll
i will virtually shake your hand on that
now but why don't you guys come on my
radio show or tv show we'll start
talking about it
we'd love to absolutely listen uh we've
got uh some locals questions to ask you
but also we've got our final question as
you know which is always
what is a one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
courage uh it
it came to me in the last nine months of
doing my show that
it doesn't really matter what what the
issue is that that's
dearest to your heart whether it's
illegal migration
uh freedom of speech cancel culture here
in america the second amendment
whatever it is um
the only thing we're lacking really in a
shocking extent is
courage and and i saw this here in in
this country the
the the willingness to to genuflect at
the altar of
dr fauci and everybody else and neil
ferguson these
dooms saying you know you know cretins
who were unelected
when we're talking about a disease that
had a 0.4
mortality rate uh in which children were
practically invulnerable and i saw it
today i almost said something i was
walking my dog
past the playground and this you know
handsome black guy is walking his
daughter
and he's got no mask but he's got a mask
on his kid
and i felt like saying i mean have you
looked at the statistics are you insane
this is child abuse so courage courage
courage it's like sergey nitzin said
that the biggest thing you can do for
the dictators
is to not cleave to the truth and to
hide the truth
every single one of your views i mean
that's why you're watching this show
but the truth is more important than
ever and every single one of you matters
so
the truth and then a little pet request
that i always tell people
guys read books
nobody reads books anymore i love
podcasts i love social media
but we need to get back to knowledge
that has been
tested proven true so get back to the
old school as a teacher francis you know
you know this
the value of an hour a day of reading a
book with real pages
is just gold
absolutely true seb thank you so much
for coming on the show
um we're gonna do our locals questions
just after this uh where is the best
place for people to find you if they
want to find you if they want to see
your content
uh go to my webpage said gawker.com
that's
s-e-b-g-o-r-k-a-seb gorku.com but i'm on
all the platforms said gawker on twitter
sebastian underscore gawker on instagram
facebook you name it
um just look up sebastian or said gawker
and you'll find me and
and the tv show you can watch for free
on newsmax
uh download the newsmax app and it's the
gawker reality check
every sunday seb thanks for coming on
and thank you all for watching this
fascinating conversation i say i've
really enjoyed it playing a bit of
devil's advocate with someone
who knows how to do that and and play
along with it uh
thank you for watching we will see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
or raw show and as you can see some
pretty serious people watch the raw
shows
make sure you tune in as well absolutely
and don't forget
keto is for slags thank you very much
and goodbye guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using
the link below